hello everyone and welcome to today's
presentation
on engineering the next generation of
sales for protein biology
i am lisa from nexon bioscience where we
have a team of experts in the science of
cell counting and cell-based assays
and i will be your moderator for today's
event before we begin
i would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions
as you would like during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
we will answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
in addition if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
i am excited to present today's speaker
dr bjorn voldberg
director of chose cell line development
at the technical university of denmark
for a complete biography of dr goldberg
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen so without any
further ado
i would like to hand it over to dr
vollborg
thank you very much and thank you for
giving me the opportunity to present our
work here
uh it's always nice to present work uh
scientific work to a good audience and
even better if it's something we're
proud of which i
actually am i'm pretty proud of what
we've been doing here so
uh i'll be talking about the the
engineering of the next generation of
chill cells for protein production
uh the work that's been going on at the
technical university of denmark for the
past eight years
so
just very briefly on who we are i'm
working at the novo nordisk foundation
center for biosustainability
at the technical university of denmark
it's important for me to stress that
we're
not affiliated with nuvo nordisk
we're not a part of novo nordisk we're
funded by the novo nordisk foundation
which is a foundation
like the bill gates foundation in the us
or the welcome trust in the uk
a foundation that makes a lot of its
funds from the
owning of a big chunk of both nouveau uh
novo nordisk and novozymes
but it's giving them money with no
strings attached
into the scientific community and
through academic research
and the center for biosustainability is
a center that is focused on the
generation of cell factories so
basically we see
cells as small factory buildings that
are engineerable
as that can be engineered to produce
better what is already producing or
producing completely new
products um we're
doing this both in microbial
cell factories mainly to produce small
chemical compounds
and then also in cho cells where the the
goal is to produ
become better at producing therapeutic
proteins
we want to do this uh so so this has
been doing done in both with basic
research
half the funding more or less is going
into doing classic basic research
with groups of post docs and phd
students
and then also the other half we'll be
going is going into translational
research
which is running core facilities and
that with staff scientists and
technicians
where the goal here is to actually take
the knowledge from the basic research
groups and use that to
generate cell lines and tools that can
be used
into industry and go out into the
real non-academic world another big
scope for us is the development of
talents to educate postdocs phds
and also to attract scientists into the
copenhagen
uh and uh southern medicon valley
uh region of of denmark and southern
sweden
so uh the cho program uh is
funded by the novo nordis foundation it
was approved in may 2012 and we got a
funding of
about 60 million u.s dollars for eight
years which is a good
funding i'd say it consists of four
scientific sections and one course
section
and we will be we are addressing
the major challenges in the in the
field so when we started this program we
went out and we talked to pharma
companies to
see what do you really want we have this
program we are starting up
which what would you like us to focus on
and we went to pharma companies but if
you look at the
kind of the headings here quantity
quality time
that's probably what you would get as an
answer no matter which industry you talk
to
they want a lot a very good quality
product
fast but if we split it up into more of
the
the recombinant world you see that that
there is some more specific
areas to address we want high tiders
which makes it cheaper to produce
that can be addressed through through
transgene expression translation
transport folding cell viability and so
on
you want it to be able to purify it
relatively quick
and efficiently to avoid immunogenicity
degradation to avoid losses
in purification and contaminations you
want to be able to control the post
translation modifications
and this is something that we've been
doing a lot of and i'll be
addressing that quite a bit later on and
then you would also like to to do this
quick
so get a quick development time and a
stable expression over time
and we're looking into that as well so
the green
uh words here are the areas that we've
been focusing on
in the program so
um the cho cells what are they
they are the preferred hosts for the
production of biotherapeutic
glycoproteins
the reason for that is that they have
this
more or less the same pro translation
modifications as the human
proteins they have human-like glycans
not completely and i'll get back to that
in
later as well they have a good capacity
for folding it correctly and
secreting they have a low transmission
of viruses high protein yield
they're highly adaptable they are
actually extremely adaptable and they
you can basically do almost anything to
show cells and they will adapt along the
way
um they have a long fda history they
originally come from
were taken out of china back in 48 or 49
the hamsters themselves and there was
some discussions over
over the co during the cold war that the
the
the there was a worry that that the cia
and others
it was mainly china worrying that they
would be using these as hosts for
biological warfare
like parachuting in small
small hamsters with diseases
i don't think that ever happened you
never know
but today they're actually become the
host
of uh protein drugs that have been used
to cure
millions of people around the globe uh
and that is
the focus that i'm looking at and that
is why we
really want to look at these to make
better production cell lines
so the jocelyns are secreting cell lines
it's kind of
uh funny because there there were some
colleagues of mine made a transcriptomic
study of all human organs
to try and see okay all human organs
what are they actually producing
and if you can see here this is a graph
of
secreted proteins from different organs
ovaries are actually really really bad
at
secreting proteins another organ that is
just
almost just as bad as the kidney which
is kind of weird when you
first think of it because this is cho
cells and hex cells
which you would expect which basically
are the
main two mammalian cell lines to produce
secreted proteins
but when you think of it back in the
days
the problem here was actually not as
much as getting a lot of protein
as even more to actually be able to
purify it
from the media and having cell lines
that secrete
low levels of whole cell proteins by
themselves
actually makes the media cleaner and
makes it easier to produce
a pure fiber so this
is the classical way of doing this so
people would have their in-house cell
line
they would make a stable polyclonal pool
by transfecting in their genes of
interest
they would do some rounds of
amplification to see if they can amplify
the genes they would
single cell clone a single clone the
screen for the best high producers
and then they would go and screen for an
optimal buyer process
and this can be a very lengthy project
process and they would be doing this
again for the next gene of interest
what we want to go is actually to have
cell lines that are specialized for the
production of different proteins
we want to be able to control the
glycosylation we want to have targeted
integration sites
we want to have a robust bioprocess a
facilitated downstream processing and a
faster upstream development
doing all this you should be if you
think of it i would actually
i'd like to say that i would like that
show cells to become almost almost e
coli cell
except for the growth rate but if you
produce try and produce proteins from e
coli cell you would not start screening
clones you would assume that they are
all producing more or less the same
and that's also what we're aiming at you
especially using targeted gene insertion
sites we're actually able to make cells
that basically
all will produce the same high levels of
protein so you will not have to screen
for large
screen large batches of clones to figure
out and get the best producer
the cho program is an all-inclusive
program so we are looking we both have
the
bioinformatics side looking at all the
omics analyzing large amounts of data
we also have a glycosylation group that
are looking into
understanding the glycosylation i'll be
coming back to that
protein production phenotype so on and
so forth
the scientific sections are spread out
over two three universities on two
continents
actually four universities on three
countries and two continents
we have a genome scan modeling group at
the university of california in san
diego headed by nathan lewis
who is the bioinformatic groups so they
have been generating silicone models of
joe and
analyzing a lot of this big data that we
have been sending over there
uh we have a chill cell line engineering
and design group uh here at dtu
they have been designing a lot of the
tools needed to
to engineer joe and they're looking very
much into the investigation of the joe
secretary machinery er stress responses
product quality and so on
we had a group at the university of
copenhagen that has been looking into
understanding the glycosylation
machinery and joe of cho cells and axial
and then
use we have used this these knowledges
to improve the
glycosylation machinery and engineer the
glycosylation machinery of chill cells
and then we had a group at the
university of uh of the
the technical high school in in the
royal technical
university in in stockholm sweden that
has expressed and purified the human
sacrosome
basically more than 2000 proteins
expressed and purified from cho
very systematically which have given us
a very large data set
of which proteins can be expressed in
chosen which cannot
and then there's the chocor which is the
translational part
which is headed by me and we've been
focusing a lot on making these cell
lines so we have been
looking very much into making the
cellular engineer the cell lines
where we started out with the gmp ready
cell line and have been
monitoring very tightly anything these
cells have seen
so they should be ready relatively
quickly to actually go back into gmp
facilities if needed
we've been looking into glycosylation to
increase the expression levels to get a
clean and viruses
cell line and also try and eliminate
process variants especially lactate that
i will come back to
we've been doing this by running a high
throughput social cell line
engineering platform where we designed
knocking knockouts and then did the
manipulations in
in high throughput i'll get back to that
in a minute
then we analyze the cell lines using
different approaches
we have expressed and purified number of
multiple of
modern proteins and we're actually also
producing therapeutic candidates
by generating new drugs with specific
tailor-made
glycosylations on them
the knockout pipeline this high
throughput pipeline of the choker that
i've
just mentioned for cell line engineering
especially
not g knockout is is looking like this
so we have the target identification
uh reagent design which in this case is
gardeners as we're using crisprs
we use these to redesign the garden a's
clone them into
a high throughput screen for the best
gardener we would typically clone
more than one or two maybe four
guidelines per target to pick the best
ones
then we prep them up transfect into the
cho cells
uh using a cas9 that
is is uh is fused to gfp
and then we can use the facts to sort
these out into three 84 well plates
that goes they grow there they go on to
a celico
and then to figure out which wells have
actually growth in them
and then a robot picks them from the
384-wheel plates into 96 well plates
we grow them up sacrifice two-thirds of
them three-thirds of them
quarters of them for next-gen sequencing
to detect which ones have indels
in the genes we want and the rest then
with
the last 25 will then be expanded
selected and picked for
either rescue plate that goes into the
freezer or it gets expanded into
shake floss and bank that way we have
generated more than 700
uh different specifically engineered cho
cell lines over the years now
the cell lines are then getting analyzed
so we transfect them with model proteins
we select clones we look at protein
expression
we purify the protein we characterize
the proteins
we generate data for a number of omics
analysis and we also look at the
phenotypes and growth viability and so
on and so forth with the chosens
so when we want to use the cell lines as
a factory building as i mentioned before
we want to be able to control the
protein production in the chill cells
and to do this we need to know which
parts are in the factory
so we need to know which genome
sequences are actually there
we publish the genomes of the cho and
actually also of the original hamster
some years ago
so we know what we have we need to
understand how the
machines are talking together how the
genes the proteins are talking together
so we've been doing a lot of modeling
or nate has been doing a lot of modeling
with his people in san diego
to understand how the machinery and the
network inside the cell
is actually looking we have
tried to understand the
post-translational
modifications especially glycosylations
through the golgi
understand the metabolic networks within
the cho cells
so which metabolize goes where and then
we have spent quite a bit of time also
to actually get the tools ready to be
able to engineer all this
so with this we've generated a number of
different cell lines and i'll go through
some of them now
one of the first ones we did was
actually to try and clean up the cho
so we basically have been looking into
which whole cell proteins are actually
swimming around when it shows cell
growth
grows and then we started knocking them
out so we
we took first we knocked six out then we
added five on top of those and at the
end we added three more
to clean up the chill cells and um
we can show that we actually by doing
just these 14 or actually maybe even
just the 11
we actually reduce the the wholesale
protein load of the cells by about 50
and we increase the cell by the viable
cell density and actually also the
viability over time by use by knocking
out these
6 11 and 14 genes
we've also looked into one of the things
that have been
a problem for especially by a process
over a long time
which is the tendency for chill cells to
produce
lactate when they grow lactate
gets secreted out of the chill cell it
lowers the ph
and then you'll need you typically add
base to keep the ph
constant at some point the you change
the osmolarity of the media and that
actually decreases the viability of the
child cells in there
there's been a lot of work going on
trying to remove these pathways to see
if we could get
rid of the lactate especially by
targeting the ldha gene but it has not
really been done
in a way that it wasn't possible to do
them all to knock out ldha
it seems to be lethal but we actually
managed by
knocking out both ldha and pdk
one to four we managed to knock out
the ldha gene thereby generating a
cell line that does not produce produce
any lactate
it shows and
the postdoc who who designed this
obviously went online and actually found
a hamster dressed up as godzilla which
we kind of took to our hearts so this is
the chozilla here
as you can see it it does not produce
any lactate at all the
the if you look at the at the figure on
the top right
the red line at the bottom is actually
the lactate so there is 0.0
lactate in this it just doesn't produce
any lactate
it shows higher viability and also
reaches a higher viable cell density
over time so this is one of the other
ones that we're actually pretty proud of
then i'll be focusing the remainder of
my talk mainly on the glycosylation
so we've been doing a lot of work on
glycosylation machinery
glycosylation of the therapeutics of
therapeutic protein is important
it's a quality attribute that it's needs
to be
reported to the fda so when you get a
drug
that you put on the market you you have
to deliver in a
glycoprofile and you have to keep all
batches you produce along the line
a long time uh you need to keep it
within these specs
black hands having it has an uh
significantly often a significant impact
on the efficiency activity
immunogenicity stability and the
half-life
of your drugs so it matters
the universe the group at the university
of copenhagen spent
the first four years of the program to
to develop
and understand and investigate the the
understand the machinery of the cho
cells and we use this knowledge to then
engineer a set of gel cells that
actually can
make tailor-made glycans and we
validated these on wholesale proteins
and model proteins
to show that that we can actually
make cell lines with taylormade
glycosylation and this is just one
example
uh the first one so here we have knocked
out six glycogens
and if you look on the left side you can
see a glycoprofile from wild type cho
cells
and on the right side we have knocked
out six
of the glycogens that the chill cell has
it can now only make biointendery
glycans we have we're analyzing this and
the natural wholesale protein secrete
the whole sub proteins from the joe cell
and we do that because we want to
understand the glycosylation machinery
here we do not want to be
have influence on the bio of the protein
itself
there might be biases towards which
glycans can is there room for and
different like antibodies would
almost all of them only have biancinary
because there's no room for anything
larger so this is
on a variety of proteins and that gives
us a very robust idea of what the cell
actually can make
and we've used this to make a full panel
of
cell lines so we've made a large
panel of of cell lines that we can pick
you want to monitor in a bio antenna try
antenna or a tetra antenna
or you can have it without glucose with
oxalic acid
galactosis and so on so it's trimmed
both ways
which gives you a pretty good tool uh
if you want to investigate a
glycosylation of your protein
and why would you want to do that so the
way you normally
uh make a protein that you will go into
clinical trials
you make a high producer joke loan and
then you pick
the best mo often the best high produce
the best producer you have
which may give a very heterogeneous
glycosylation side
so you have different versions of the
protein with different glycans on it
but what you would actually really like
is actually to be able to figure out
which glycoform of these is actually the
best
so if you take the the panel that i just
described
before and express a little bit of your
protein in each of these you can get you
end up with
up to 30 different glycovariants of your
protein
you can then test that in your essays to
pick
the best glycoform you can uh you you
that that you want to go forward with
and then you take that and go into
clinic
that same cell line can then actually be
used to produce
the proteins going forward and the scale
up and actually
end up going all the way to
manufacturing with a cell and it will
make the glycan you want and not the
heterogeneous
variants that you have we've done this
so this is just a very rough example of
what we've done
so this is eight examples of how
glycoprofiles look when we have
used epo into the cell lines um
and in a shake flask so there's nothing
fancy here there's no
large bio process and you can see that
we're actually
this is different variants of epo this
is epo with different glycans on it
and you can see that it's actually you
can pick and get your glycans with
different
or get your protein with very defined
glycostructure glycoprofiles on them
we've done this with a number of
proteins
one of the things that we figured out is
there's a lot of
the liver is secreting quite a bit of
protein into the plasma
and it turns out that most of the
proteins produced by the liver
actually have a very defined bioantenary
non-fuecosylated
glycoprofile and this have
may have or actually has a very large
effect on at least some of the proteins
maybe
more than you'd think uh so so
you need to have the real glycan the
this biotinary glycoform on your protein
to actually make it work uh one example
of this
is alpha one antitrypsin alpha one
antitrypsin is a
is a protein that protects the lungs
from degradation
from neutrophil elastase it's a protease
inhibitor
uh p there's a number of patients who
are born without
uh alpha one antitrypsin either they
miss the gene or they have a variant
that makes it it never
makes it out of the liver and the
symptoms they get is kind of
like smoker's lungs so you get this
long degraded over time the treatment is
augmentation therap therapy so they go
into
the hospital typically once a week get
doses from four grams and up
i heard up to 10 12 grams of protein
that they will need to get alpha one and
two trypsin in
the products on the market are all
derived from fractionated human plasma
and there
is no recombinant proteins there and why
is that
so the aat from cho is uh
we we looked at it and and if you look
at alpha 1 and description of aat
expressed in normal to cells you see a
very heterogeneous
profile if you look at what gets out of
the human plasma it's
like i mentioned before with from the
liver very specific by itinerary
and we had a cell line as i showed
before that was actually pretty close to
this
so we had a cell line that in this case
was by itinerary still had the fucos on
and it
didn't have salic acids and
to make a long story short we managed to
make a cell line that can actually
produce
alpha one and two trypsin uh in the
bottom
uh right corner that is this
is recombinantly produced alpha one and
two trips and from our chill cell which
is very similar to both the
commercial drug on the market which is
derived from plasma
also very similar to plasma derived aac
that we derived ourselves a few
fractionated cells and very different
from when you produce
aet in in wild capture cells
we managed to pick some high producer
clones of this
and ended up into a 1.4 grams per liter
in the first media screen in a
bioreactor
and this is stable over time so after 63
days we still have a cell line that can
produce
high levels of the of alpha one
antitrypsin with the correct
glycoprofile on it
and we scale this up also to five
milliliters and we've
shown that it actually on an sds page
and
isoelectric focusing it looks very very
much
like the plasmid derived versions and
very different from the cho
wild type show derived versions there
are some advantages of this
uh one of the things that you can start
doing if you have a recombinant l for
one or two trips instead of plasmazing
you can start manipulating it so you can
either get as i mentioned before
alternative glycosylations which could
be interesting for some diseases
you can add more uh glycosylation site
for improved half-life
you can do stabilizing mutation you can
actually even change the affinity
so if there's if you change if you do
some mutations in the
in the active site of alpha one is it
trypsin it suddenly gets very
uh active again it gets a very high
affinity against fury instead of
neutrophil elastase so that might
actually be a potential drug for other
places where you would like to get rid
of urine
maybe like at the very open time core
19 where actually the spike protein
needs a furing cleavage
to be able to bind to the ace receptor
to infect cells
we can make a very low batch of batch
variation and the fact that
you make it recombinant also means that
we're not depending
on getting protein from patients who
donate blood
you can formulate it you cannot
concentrate it you can even
add fusions to it so you might even add
targeting proteins or something to get
it to go to the right organs or the
right places in the body in the future
if that's what you want
so one experiment that we've done is
we'll actually produce quite a bit of
proteins here we have mentioned i
mentioned 10 proteins that we have made
and purified in in all 30 cell lines
uh just to make different variants of
these
uh and we're actually looking for more
proteins uh
we will be starting up a protein
production facility using
the amount of other things these
glycoengineered cell lines
so if anybody out there has the need for
proteins with specific glycans on them
that they would like to test out
please approach me on my email after
this and i'll be
happy to talk further about how we can
do this
so the future perspectives of this is
that we are looking at completely new
protein-based drugs
we have unnatural proteins you can make
fusions you can make all kind of
different things that you could not
do before we make proteins that cannot
be made in cho today
we are looking into we're making
proteins without design glycoprofiles as
i mentioned
and also by doing using targeted
integration and other approaches
we're able to go much faster from bench
to pharmacy
looking into cheaper development and
cheaper production
of therapeutic proteins going forward
with this i'd like to acknowledge all
the people involved in this
uh my group at the technical university
of
of uh denmark and also the program
partners and the the
partners in the joe program bernard
paulsen who is the
professor at ucsd and he's also the
grand holding pi
kim min lee and lee shigao from kaist
and dtu
nathan lewis from ucsd matthias yulin
and johanna rockberg at the
in stockholm and henlike klaus and zhang
yang at the university of copenhagen
and then we've had some collaborators
especially on the alpha one entry trips
in richarli duke at the
university of in canada and jerry
mcilvaney at the
beaumont hospital in ireland and with
that i just want to acknowledge the
funding and the support from the novo
nordisk foundation and the
ndtu and uh that's basically it
i'll be ready for questions in the q a
session later
thanks dr goldberg that was great very
informative
we already have a lot of great questions
uh coming into the chat box for you
for now i would like to introduce our
second speaker dr henry causey
who is an application scientist here at
nexlun for complete biography on dr qazi
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr kazi you may now begin your
presentation
thank you very much lisa
so this is going to be the
instrumentation side of the discussion
specifically about this lego image
cytometer and how it is used
in the cell line development community
for engineering the next generation of
cells
and protein production uh just as a
brief
background for anyone who doesn't know
who next lung bioscience is
our motto is essentially that we want to
deliver better tools or better biology
we have done this by over the last 17
years
essentially designing and manufacturing
cell-based anatomy systems
out of boston north of boston
massachusetts
and providing these image cytometry
technologies
our approach along with just being a
worldwide company
with myself located in san diego is
essentially to have scientists helping
scientists to increase
accuracy and really do this helps and
spread
best practices with other labs
what this does essentially is bring
scientists like myself
i have a background that includes doing
crispr editing
along with doing single cell cloning
and pretty much doing that the same type
of type of work that bjorn was
discussing
earlier and it brings groups like me
and him and other labs together where we
can essentially collaborate
um and we have several publications that
are
peer-reviewed in the cell line
development community uh so i welcome
anyone to just explore the next salaam
website and to just further look at some
of these publications
so the selego has been really integrated
heavily into the cell line development
community we have been from the very
beginning steps where you can start out
with doing transfection
determining transfection efficiency of
your cells
looking at the stability of those cells
in terms of doing stabilized
outgrowth monitoring cells within wells
and identifying which populations to
essentially move forward
along with optimization of the whole
process uh
has been used by seligo in the earlier
stage and then
classically uh the telego image
statometer is used
to verify a monoclonality whether it's
through
limited dilutions or single cell
dispensing
and then using it towards colony
outgrowth
so uh just what is silica so seligo ima
cetometer uh essentially provides
fast time saving high throughput
analysis
uh for imaging and provides the ability
to do
like document monoclonality uh and
expansion of your products with great
ease the goal is essentially to have
an ability to essentially automate
things uh be able to scale up
productivity uh without sacrificing
validation of your data and selego
allows for
uh plate-based imaging uh with uh
probably the fastest uh image cytometer
in the market
which allows for accurate cell-based
assays using both whole well bright
field
and fluorescence imaging and it's mainly
used as a screening tool
uh within the cell line development
community
the way that seligo does this and what's
proprietary about
the mechanics is that it has what we
call f data lenses
and galvanometric mirrors which
essentially allow for
speed to capture larger areas
of that you want image and then as you
look in the middle
accuracy going all the way to the edge
of the well we often say
that seligo picks up every cell in every
well
which allows you whether you have
adherent cell suspension cells whether
you're doing a colony outgrowth
and oftentimes when you're doing single
cell dispensing or doing clonality
cells have this nice tendency to roll
all over to the edge of a well
the seligo allows you to quickly and
accurately pick up that
single cell at the edge as well
the workflow is actually pretty simple
when you think about the celia and how
it can be used within the single cell
sorting
and single-celled colony growth
essentially you either
use limited dilutions or you uh
sort yourselves out into a plate of your
choice like a 96 wall plate or a 384
plate uh put it into the seligo and the
seliga will do a whole well image and it
spits out
uh your data for you and then you can
get these really nice heat maps which
i'll discuss in a second
uh the seligo was essentially designed
with the user in mind so it's
really designed for like a simplified
workflow where you just go from restart
you introduce you put your plate in you
put your scan parameters on you analyze
yourself do any kind of gating if you
need to
in terms of like doing population
identification if you're doing
transfection efficiency and then you get
your results
uh and then the software can be
simplified as simple as
two or three clicks to get from
introducing your plate to getting your
results
and this is why the seligo is very loved
in the cell line development community
so the heat maps that i was discussing
and wanted to share with you so when you
get to the results
stage and you want quick verification of
what you have actually
seeded and played it when you're doing
single cell seating a heat map can be
generated essentially creating a legend
like on the right side where you can say
something like if i have more than one
cell
mark it red if i haven't don't have a
cell in there mark it
as yellow this allows for color coding
visual confirmation of what you played
it and really aids in the entire
workflow and
helps with the accuracy of seating panel
c is an example where somebody
essentially uses lego and fed back and
towards
optimizing their cell printing platform
so with
limited dilutions you can be very lucky
if you get a third
of your population as a single cells per
well
and that's the example of the larger
heat map that you see in the back
but what you can do is you can optimize
your cell printer
to essentially get towards an accuracy
level of
about 97 according to this specific
study
a few studies have shown that if you use
both the combination of two instruments
both the stealth sorter
or printer and verify with the seligo
you can essentially get an assurance of
like 100 percent that you are actually
successfully
seating a single cell and using a single
salting grow
into a colony
uh here's an example of using and
getting
a very quick information right from day
zero
so one of the processes that is often
recommended is essentially
instead of having to wait for seven days
ten days or two weeks to see if i have a
colony growing
uh is to quickly identify your single
cells within that single well right away
so that you know what to expect and you
can really
develop your processes and be prepared
to deal with the specific samples
ahead of time so this methodology
for example uses actually a transient
dye and for transient dyes it is often
recommended that if you're doing any
kind of fluorescent labeling
that it should be limited to reagents
that do not interfere with the integrity
of the cell line itself
so normally i recommend transient dyes
such as cm fda
which uh during single cell cloning it
doesn't interfere with
the safety or overall product quality
and this has been
shown with through several studies but
if you can use fluorescence and bright
field to analyze it
it really reinforces the assurance of
monoclonality especially for
documentation purposes
so here's just a quick example where we
had
uh this is showing one well out of our
entire plate where
they essentially did single cell sorting
of both gfp
and m cherry cells so mixed population
and try to see and make sure
that we did get successful analysis
using fluorescent channel or
bright field alone to verify single
cells and so here's an example where
we see that indeed only one m cherry
cell
was stained in that location where you
can see in the
on the left panel and no other cells
were present within the swell
and visual verification is very easy to
do within salio software
i did want to take this opportunity to
mention that we did have
a new application that just came out
called modernize your style documents
cell development assays with high
throughput image cytometry and it is
also an article that is available
on cell culture dish here's
an image from that article essentially
showing the single cell uh
plating within uh this well for example
and plane a shows
uh the use of a transient uh dye
and if you are not to use a transient
dialect you can use gfp transpected
cells or m cherry cells but usually
those are recommended for
non-clinical research but if you need to
be able to verify it
in just bright field alone plane panels
b
and c show the images in just a
bright field a single cell and its
identification in panel c
and then you can essentially know right
away that you had a successful
uh seating protocol instead of having to
wait several days
and then a few days later i believe this
was in four or five days
and uh panel d you see a nice colony
growing in the bottom left
of that well uh that's uh an image
overlay
uh like a color overlay over right field
just for identification purposes
for just visual verification and
panel e and f show uh what that looks
like at least within the software
of identifying that signal colony that
arrived from a single cell
and so this process can be done in high
throughput and it's very easy to
essentially identify those
single cells to single colony growths
i did i would be remiss if i did not
mention new developments within the cell
line development community
many researchers and many sites have
actually started using
our celica high throughput cell counter
in the middle
which essentially allows them to count
24 samples
in three minutes or less it's become
really useful
in cell line engineering processes
production manufacturing
it's been a relief for a lot of people
that have had existing bottlenecks
where now they can count hundreds of
samples within minutes instead of hours
and for people that do uh cho cell work
often times you can bring that down to
counting taking 24 samples and counting
them in about a minute
uh so it's actually become a very
successful instrument uh within the
cell line development community and
essentially it's a dedicated cell
counter which really helps
just move samples along quickly checking
for viability in south house
the other thing i did want to mention is
just next along by science's role
overall
we are unique in providing support and
resources
to the cell line development community
next alone bioscience is committed to
supporting
the community by providing documentation
assays protocols
and essentially providing a complete
image cytometry solution to advance
research and therapeutics as best as we
can and at the very basic level
you have access to scientists like
myself who have done this type of
research
and we can even give recommendations of
like what type of plates
uh to use and what is popular in the
field uh for your specific application
if you need it
um so overall the seligo provides like
fast time saving
high throughput analysis and imaging
solutions uh with the
ability to essentially document
monoclonality and expansion with great
ease
and you can use this ligo not just for
just single cell to colony out growth
but for
lots of other applications which are
available
to be explored by yourself at nexlon.com
with that that is the end of my
presentation i will take any questions
or hand it over you lisa
thanks henry that was great uh we
already have questions coming in
everybody feel free to put in questions
uh
into the chat box and for the first
question is for you henry
can these cell counters count primary
cells
actually they can so what is really
great with primary cells is you can use
a nuclear stain dyes we
recommend accurate in orange purple
iodide which essentially
gets rid of any of those background
signals that you might have from primary
cells
uh debris all of that gets ignored and
you get your very accurate live dead
counts
and it and the celica is essentially
designed to do this in high throughput
awesome next question is for you dr
goldberg
is it possible unless are there efforts
to humanize the glycosylation
pattern in short cells yes it's not only
possible and there are efforts actually
it's one of the things i i realized that
i skipped too quickly over the alpha one
antitrypsin variants that we are making
are actually made exactly making using
a humanized glycoform where it's
typically what typically is the question
here is is the cylic acids
whether it's a two three or a two one
three or two six
salic acids and two six are the ones
that are prevalent in in humans
and that is what we we knocked out the
the
one three cylic acid transferases and
put in the human one so
these are making humanized glycose
so the answer is yes great
so the next question is also for you dr
rolberg
great talk they say i was wondering if
the production
of hiv-1 proteins specifically the
integrase protein
could be performed with these cells
probably i don't know about the
integrase protein a lot so it's
a bit hard to say uh if it's a secreted
protein
naturally then it would probably be
glycosylated and then be interested
for uh to produce and chose cells but if
it's an integrase i guess it's working
intracellularly so it might not be
uh the question is i don't know
i don't know not enough about the
protein for this
okay uh how accurate is the single cell
gfp sort
do you manually check your single cell
in single well seating by
eye that's for dr goldberg
yeah no we don't uh we use a seligo
so um we we we believe that that the
singles and sword is actually pretty
accurate
the gfp is as i mentioned fused to the
cast nine
so we mainly use it to to enrich for
the transfected cells if if there's no
cas9 in
in the pro in the cell it's not relevant
because then it's not going to get
engine
gene edited by uh for us and then we
they'd get single cell sorted out into
384 well plates and then we use the
celico to figure out
which wells have growth in them and then
we pick from that
we don't look specifically whether it's
a single cell or not
we would figure it out when we look at
the
at the number of uh genetic engineering
genetic
edits if we get too many different ones
it's probably more than one clone and
then we would discard it
okay you mentioned that historically it
was an issue that cell lines had too
much
secreted proteins in the medium how do
you select for high
producer secretor cell clones
specifically your protein of interest
but not other proteins or is it that no
longer
an issue like it was historically
i mean i mean historically it's not as
much an issue as it was because the
purification techniques have
improved uh dramatically since so it's
been a lot easier to produce
purify protein out of this media but but
we are looking into it
normally what we see is that we get
about half a milligram of
of secreted whole cell proteins in in
the media
and you would normally when you look for
high producer clones you would be
looking at
cells that are producing almost grams
per liter or more
so in that case it's negligible you
don't look for
ones with very little wholesale proteins
but
by removing them as we've done in one
experiment
and one cell line it gets easier to you
get fewer co-purifying proteins down the
line
so it's more like proteins that tend to
stick to your protein
to your to your protein or that gets
problematic when you need to purify the
weight
those are the ones that we removed
okay do you primarily use cho cells for
all the engineering
or do you use other cell lines such as
sf9 or heck 293
well the cho program is a cho program so
it's we mainly looked at
cho cells but we've done actually some
work in in heck as well so we made
actually a hex zela version
uh as well but the the focus has been on
the show and that's because the focus of
the whole program is on show and and
the use of cho cells for uh production
of therapeutic programming
it's the work main workhorse used by
industry so that's why we focused on
that
okay this next person says thank you for
these great presentations
a couple of questions so the first one
is
which purification methodology do you
use
and which provides optimum yield for
recombinant protein production
well we use chromatography so it's it's
basically a
column purification uh the
specific methodology of which columns
depend obviously on the protein
if we can stick if we can stick a tag on
it
his tag for instance then we can use
specific nickel columns to purify
using the his-tag if it's antibodies
there's specific protein a
columns for that uh if we like for the
alpha one and two trips and well you
cannot have tags on it
we developed uh us i think a three-step
purification protocol using some iron
exchange and
size exclusion to to get a reasonably
pure protein
okay the second part of the question was
how would you validate proteins
functional confirmation and
post-translational modification within
your methods
so the functional confirmation we try to
see if we can get a we can make a
an activity essay so with the alpha one
and two trips and we test it
to see whether it can inhibit uh
elastase
in individualized so it's actually a
fairly simple one
if it's an antibody we can look at the
affinity that it still will bind to its
target
and the post translation modifications
we're mainly looking at glycosylation
and the glycosylation we validate using
fluorescently labeled
we shave off the glycans label them
fluorescently and run them
on a mass spec and then we get the
profiles
giving the figures that i showed in my
presentation
okay another question for dr goldberg
have there been any issues with
cryopreservation after show lines
have been produced do you see this being
important down the line
we have not seen any any
any problems with cryopreservation i
mean it's just
we store them in liquid nitrogen like
you would store any other chocolates and
we
have so far have not seemed to reach to
metal with anything that would make them
hard to store there
that would be you could imagine that you
could end up doing that
some of the glycosylated glycoengineered
cell lines are actually hard to
transfect if you use electroporation
but that's another story that's probably
because by altering cylic acid levels
you
actually alter the the charge of the
cell and thereby
the standard protocols for
electroporation of cells will not work
anymore because it looks differently
from an electro electric point of view
okay in addition to vcd
ph and temperature what would be the top
several
variables of a cho culture to actively
monitor for
a successful batch vcd
get the highest vcd you can get that's
the one then you get the highest
production
okay so this last person says it is
really interesting how we can use
proteins as treatment
i have no experience on that but it does
look interesting
at the end of the day the molecular
biology dogma
congrats and i hope the good job keeps
coming i know this may be a little
off topic but do you have any knowledge
on pvdf
and its potential use for protein
adhesion outside of western blot
uh the question here the answer is no i
don't i don't have any knowledge on what
has been used i could imagine
that you could use it if you want to get
rid of all proteins from
media whatever but it's extremely
as as you know it's very unspecific it
will bind any protein
at all so you cannot use it to select
[Music]
for the protein you want
okay i have one more question that came
in what is the theoretical limit of cho
for igg production
that's a good question if you look at at
if you if you take it a step further and
look at what a plasma cell produces in
the human body
then we're talking 200 picograms per
cell per day
what we can reach in the cho cell is
about a quarter of that i would imagine
maybe even this i think i've heard about
15 to 20 grams per liter in really
optimized
where you really have spent a lot of
time optimizing the buyer processes and
getting
the highest produce and so on in an
industrial setting
i mean it can probably be expanded much
more if we really
put efforts into it
okay looks like that's all of our
questions we have for today
thank you both for great presentations
and thank you to our audience for taking
the time to attend
today's presentation questions that were
not
we were not able to answer during
today's session if you have any
additional ones we can answer them via
email
using the contact information you
submitted when you registered for the
event
we do ask that you complete a short
survey at the close of the webinar
your thoughts and comments are greatly
appreciated
and also make sure you visit the poster
hall and exhibit booths where you can
learn more about a variety of exciting
technologies
this webcast will be available to be
viewed on demand as it has been recorded
today
so until next time we hope you have a
great day and enjoy the cell-based
essays
virtual symposium thank you